me too was not my thing my thing was I
was curious to see if I could cause
society to be like it was a random
number like 10% smarter mmm I was like
can I push the button on a social reset
can I get men and women to look at each
other as human walkabouts come with me
Josh Smith and today we are joined by
the incredible Rose McGowan how are you
I am so so well how are you I'm great
I'm even fella because I have this in my
hand which is a paper version of brave
your memoir now what I want to know was
because brave is such as such a strong
powerful title what do you think of the
biggest obstacles you've had to overcome
in order to become brave it's feeling
the fear and doing it anyway and that's
how you stay brave and get brave a lot
of times your mind will tell you to do
the easier softer thing because it makes
everyone more comfortable in the short
term but in the long term every time you
give that part of yourself away you're
lessening your so you're not as vibrant
or as brave of a being so I think it's
better just to lean into the fear and be
like you know what I am scared guess
what I'm gonna do it anyway what have
you learnt from leaning into the fear
that there's a lot to be afraid of but
I've also learned that I can withstand
in huge storms what does being empowered
mean to you being empowered to me means
knowing your own power and how do you
know your own power one of the things
that I do regularly is I make a list of
all my fears and then I what would I do
if I weren't afraid and that gives me a
really good roadmap to go on we can
survive almost anything and we will be
stronger for it so the reality is yes
you can do even everything around you or
other people are telling you to be
scared because society really implants
fears it really likes to do that to
people and I disagree with that
wholeheartedly
it's that affair directly features on
that list probably I was a homeless
teenager so I think probably being
homeless scares me a lot and I kind of
made decisions in my life career
decisions decisions of people I was
worth based on this kind of really deep
grinding core fear that I had never
really addressed and finally one day I
was like okay being homeless and hungry
on the streets at 13
doesn't mean that that's gonna happen to
you now and you have to like not make
choices in your life based on these like
illusions that are like the the evil
things just going off in your head all
the time because that's not a really fun
way to live
when you come to seeing criticism about
yourself how do you deal with that I
love it
no I'm just kidding I've been loved and
hated for a very long time I've been a
polarizing figure I talk about it in
brave how there's something about me
that makes some people uncomfortable
it's just when I was little it was like
that so many people are so afraid of
doing the right thing or doing something
scary or something that requires bravery
because they're scared of someone
telling him you suck I hate you you're
ugly you're stupid
bla bla bla and I've had every single
one of those things under the Sun
levelled at me I mean there was a
website once devoted to how fat I was I
was like diagrams with like you know
just crazy but you have to understand
that you can withstand the main thing
that it's not gonna kill you when I was
looking at the press coverage he would
get a man everything came out and that
level of extreme sexism that runs
through everything even when I was
watching interviews a lot of women yes
that's the point a lot of women so where
do you think we've got to with sexism in
our SIA Tuesday you know I mean I feel
like I'm the poster child for people
who've been dealt with with sexism you
know I mean I've gotten a real extra
helping of it in this lifetime you know
it's ugly and it's stupid and it's basic
and it's boring I was raised in a
communist for the first 10 years of my
life
that gave me like a superpower I was not
raised as a gender as a race when we
talk about me too and all the things
that happen in Hollywood it becomes it's
almost feels like it hasn't really
actually perforated into everyday life I
think it has perforated in more ways
than we know but I think what we need to
fundamentally change is men not women
women will need to change absolutely
girls need to change and grow up
differently but I think this idea of
what happens to men so young like the
ones that go into finance when they go
to advertising or whatever any man they
get stolen so young and told what they
are and what they're supposed to be it
literally breaks my heart and then
get trapped in this like emotional cage
and they just lash out or they just do
what's easier it's like I'm sitting in
the king chair it's built on an illusion
but it's really comfortable so I don't
want to get out of it I might get out
you know people ask me a lot is what you
do for women I'm not sure but it's not
it's for humans me too was not my thing
my thing was I was curious to see if I
could cause society to be like it was a
random number like 10% smarter hmm I was
like can I push the button on a social
reset can I get men and women to look at
each other as human I noticed when I
shaved my head that men can hear the
words coming out of my mouth for the
first time it was a really fascinating
like almost being a test case you know
but I wondered if I could make it so
survivors of all stripes and all genders
could be heard without having to shave
their head I work in the female
dominated industry I work women every
single day we talk about female
empowerment every single day I can tell
you I never did never know where would I
do that in Hollywood who's gonna sit and
talk female empowerment in Hollywood
they'll have luncheons yeah and they'll
[ __ ] about it but they don't do
anything about it when you're talking
about women who've come out against you
as well
Oh a lot and then use that in another
interview which I was reading you called
them like female misogynist yeah and
what how is your relationship with the
sisterhood changed and how has it
evolved throughout your life well I
never had one a relationship with any
sisterhood I was a very beautiful young
woman and I was very much hated by a lot
of girls women at almost every I went to
ten different schools in 11 years what
it taught me was that I'm pretty much on
this journey by myself and it taught me
that it's really sad that girls
literally don't know how to stick up for
each other right they don't know how to
protect each other they don't know how
to network with each other like but
they're always like things like women
need to support women women I think need
to really take and girls a hard look in
the mirror at what they do
because if you're doing it to support a
power structure that's not supporting
you then you're in a cult pain and power
are such negative things that we have in
our society because they directly feed
each other and they play against each
other do you think that Fame is just as
guilty as power
in the stories and the things that
you've experienced
I think power abuse is power abuse in
any industry and any you know from the
construction worker to the
thirteen-year-old girl walking down the
street that's power abuse to the big
boss he was attacking the employees its
power abuse I mean and people like like
look at Bill Cosby he was a famous
comedian who's in jail now he used his
fame to abuse his power so it's like a
cloak it's like the Harry Potter
invisibility clone or something right
the most visible and visibility cloak
fame can cloak you by abuse of power and
being a power abusers what pushes things
and into the negative well that comes to
putting this out into the world and
writing these things down that must
obviously bring back horrific memories
yes do these ghosts that you live with
do they listen they do they really
really lessen by by walking through it
instead of just pretending that you know
everything's great and I'm so glad I
worked through all the the rage and the
pain that I had and it's led to so much
beauty on the other side that I don't
think I could have ever gotten to does
it give you also like a two fingers up
at the people who done these horrific
things to me I never thought of it that
way I just wished those people would
fall off the planet I wish they had
ceased to exist but yeah folks gonna
think about it yeah what message would
you want to send out there to say
someone who's watching this who has
someone in their life who's abusing
their power and lettering in a very very
nasty negative way and they feel like
they can't escape it because they feel
like it's the hand that feeds them what
would you want to say to them if I
survive being homeless that's not gonna
fall on you there are resources out
there there are places you can go but
more than anything start believing in
yourself little by little every day know
that the evil things that are being said
and done - are not yours know your worth
work hard create a new life because that
time is gonna go by anyway let's have
something great to show for it
it's all about being free I'd actually
can't think of enough adjectives to
describe how powerful impactful your
words are I just think you're absolutely
incredible and I just want to say thank
you for writing this you're amazing
for more videos like this and for more
great empowering content with such
incredible women as Rose make sure you
subscribe there glamming UK channels